hi i'm ria i'm a tasty producer today
i've been challenged to take common food
and make it fancy the rules are you must
completely use the food given except
package right you can only add to the
food you can buy whatever ingredients
you wish do we have a budget can i buy
truffle once you begin cooking you must
complete upgraded dish in 30 minutes
let's see what's in it
instant ramen noodle i think it might be
a guilty pleasure there is no nutritious
value in it i want to make this
something exciting make it fancy
here's what i got shrimp
sesame oil
soy sauce carrot shiitake mushrooms
bok choy ginger and garlic i'm gonna set
my timer for 30 minutes start right now
[Music]
let's get started i'm going to deep fry
ramen noodle heating oil takes a little
bit of time so i'm going to do it first
i also grow my own knife
where did it go though
you don't
so i'm gonna cut vegetables
i don't think i need this much carrot
i think i just need a half carrot for
this i'm going for
this dish i tried in japan and also like
in a chinese restaurant but it's like
american chinese restaurant so i don't
want to say it's an authentic chinese
dish but it's just like tastes really
good and i'm going to slice shiitake
mushroom
you don't want to use the stem because
it's kind of tough you can peel ginger
with spoon
so ginger i'm gonna just like chop
really finely same as garlic if you're
not comfortable with using knife
chopping something very finely you can
use grater it's much easier and safer
why do you bring your own knives i take
my knife very seriously fun fact i used
to work for a knife store as a knife
sales person knife is probably my
favorite cooking tool i
take my lady to the spa every once in a
while shopping my knife let's check the
timer oh i have 17 minutes left i should
have
planned better i should have got the
peel trim but i got the shell shrimp so
i'm gonna just
really really fast i have this thing
like weird thing
whenever i cook in front of people my
hands start shaking
so bear with me i chose shrimp for my
protein because it's really quick to
cook you can use chicken you can use
pork i'm gonna saute the shrimp this is
just a canola oil
so i'm gonna just saute until it changes
color and i like cooking with chopsticks
shrimp it's done
i have 12 minutes left oil is almost 350
so i want to start frying my ramen and i
kind of noticed this ramen noodle it's
like two things ramen stick together so
i'm gonna just break in a half it didn't
quite work but you know gonna just do it
i'm start cooking something takes longer
time to cook so i'm going to start with
carol
i'm gonna just saw a little bit because
i want to layer the flavor
now i'm adding
mushrooms
and
beef
i'm going to add ginger
and garlic
you kind of want to add garlic later
when you're cooking high heat because
garlic burns really quickly and you
don't need to put it apart
and it gives a nice flavor smells good
i'm going to add cup of water
and this seasoning packet
did you know what was in there
i don't know
i just know the flavor it's you know
ramen broth and i'm gonna just use it i
think i'm gonna just use like one
tablespoon sake
for flavoring and also when you're using
like shrimp it kind of take out those
like fishy smell
also i'm going to put sesame oil
taste it good but i think i need a
little bit more
flavor i'm going to add some soy sauce
yeah it started tasting fancy oh
i have six minutes left
okay my
ramen noodle looks looking good it looks
like a golden brown i think it's almost
done
i want to make my soup a little bit
thicker so i'm going to add water to
starch i am using potato starch but you
can use corn starch and in order to do
that
you have to make sure the soup is
boiling
and put back the shrimp
and i'm ready
i have two minutes left i can put it in
a hot pan so i can have nice good
sizzling
it's hot it has a really nice sizzle
noise and i'm done
[Music]
let me do a taste test first
[Music]
so i made a seedling pump right now i
hope you like it i'm spooking yeah enjoy
your noodles yeah do you want to be my
grandma
why can't i be a mama
no
no i would consider this fancy
oh wow
did i make it fancy or this is fancy
approved
congratulations thank you thank you
sorry this is like proper restaurant
quality
that means did i make it fancy oh yeah
it's not a competition but i feel like i
won
everyone liked that and everyone
approved i made it fancy i also really
happy it's totally different from
package noodle and it's really easy i
feel like i made it less than ten
dollars i totally encourage you making a
home and make it fancy i have a dance
you have a dance yeah show me make it
fancy
three two one make it fancy make it
[Music]
you